i got one for you i'd love you're you're
oh god you would be the best at this
your your team your team just lost a
heartbreaker your team just lost a
heartbreaker and you walked in my
coaching you're at the co you're the
coach right now at the press conference
and they say uh coach burr what do you
feel like you were out coach tonight and
and that's why your team's going home
early after after you clearly had a
better team than them
well define what clearly better means
and why you're not coaching
professionally
let me tell you something about you
[ __ ] nerds if somebody loses every
goddamn night and you guys act like like
when am i supposed to go [ __ ]
undefeated
let me tell you why you guys never made
it on a sports team because you don't
you don't have any [ __ ] heart and the
second you see a little water on the
boat you jump ship to go over to
somebody else's
you [ __ ] weasels and i guarantee you
none of you is satisfying your wife in
bed go [ __ ] yourself and kiss my ass
next week when we win next question
oh my god